et avant tout
d'apporter des éléments de clarification
qui était indispensable sur ce qui est
la souveraineté européenne et la défense
européenne en tant qu elle qu elle
apporte la sécurité mondiale et que
ensemble nous souhaitons renforcer
vraiment cette coordination ce
partenariat stratégique entre l'union
européenne et le prince
tenant à l'organisation l'un des lots
deuxième élément important aussi nous
échanger
ensemble clarifier cette heure
l'importance de la stratégie européenne
en indo pacifique
et notre volonté de coopérer
troisième élément et je tiens vraiment à
remercier le président day 2 pour les
décisions qu'il est déjà prise c'est
aussi notre coordination dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et en particulier
la présence militaire que la france a au
style avec beaucoup de ses partenaires
européens et internationaux ces
dernières semaines le président a pris
la décision de créer concret et
opérationnel
dans nos armées ont pu bénéficier qui
sont la traduction de ce soutien
ensuite nous avons ensemble actes et
plusieurs partenariats bilatéraux
sur les exports d'armement sur
le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables
sur le spatial et sur justement les
technologies les plus innovantes
nous souhaitons avoir une coopération
renforcée des initiatives industrielles
et puis enfin nous allons continuer de
travailler ensemble sur les grands
sujets ou multilatéraux le climat
le numérique
la santé comme ce jeune ingénieur
témoigner est également discussions et
des échanges renforcés en matière de
contrôle des armements qui demeure à 2
juin sujet êtres humains et voilà en
quelques mots le fruit du travail des
dernières semaines des discussions que
nous allons avoir aujourd'hui en quelque
sorte ce sont
des décisions extrêmement concrètes qui
viennent en soutien d'actions et
d'initiatives communes que nous menons
sur ses différents champs et ce qui est
pour moi la mort d'un processus vraiment
de confiance où nous bâtissons ensemble
et qui va se traduire par une
coopération renforcée sur tous ces
points merci encore président du cade du
travail fait les dernières semaines est
ici aujourd'hui
m
point
prévention des chutes d'eau
mais
[Musique]
je
serais allé
france
on y est et
[Musique]
c'est ce qui s'est produit dans le
money time
and so for me what
is
coming
et